let's go back to Capitol Hill where
Kevin McCarthy is no longer the speaker
of the house now personally I didn't
think this was necessary well I think
chip Roy Byron Donald's Scott Perry all
Freedom caucus conservatives they they
gave us would have given us the same
outcome in terms of regular order
Appropriations bills uh had and by the
way cut government spending secure the
border and and literally stand up with
the principles that Republicans need to
stand up for it all would have been done
uh but you know it is what it is at this
point what's done is now done and sadly
now Republicans they better move quickly
they've got to act swiftly they've got
to prove to you the American people that
they can govern and keep their promises
to me they've been doing a pretty good
job maybe not fast enough for many of us
but that's the way that that's that
awful Town Works sadly the sewer the
swamp now eight Republican lawmakers
joined all 208 house Democrats to oust
the speaker last night after a motion to
vacate was put forward by Florida
Congressman Matt Gates 210 out of 218
Republicans voted to keep McCarthy but
with such a slim majority it was simply
not enough for Kevin McCarthy and by the
way he didn't have to have that vote
yesterday he said all right that's the
vote you want to have I'm not going to
make a deal with the Democrats let's
have the vote I'll win or lose and you
know what I thought that took some
courage and guts on his part the eight
Republicans who turned on McCarthy had a
variety of complaints I thought some
were legitimate some not worthy of the
action they took lack of action on
Appropriations bills well I think that
Byron Donald's and Chip Roy and those
guys came up with a pretty good answer
in 30 days that would have been done and
handled uh also you know bipartisan
continuing resolutions they do have to
stop we do have to return to order we do
need to pass all 12 Appropriations bills
it was also and I know this for for a
fact sadly it was also personal you know
what it's business it shouldn't be
personal but now there will be a new
speaker we know that both house
Judiciary Committee chairman Jim Jordan
and House Majority Leader Steve scalise
they now both are officially in they are
running to be speaker
um let me tell you where I am tonight
make no mistake I like Steve scalise uh
I think he's a great leader I think he's
a really good guy he's a patriot but I I
personally am worried for him for one
very very real reason
um it's not going to be easy to run for
speaker he happens to be going through
cancer treatment right now and I want
his health to be put first I really mean
that when I say that I don't think he
should be changing his position at this
time
um with that in mind again no personal
anything involved in this my choice for
chairman my choice for speaker the best
option I think we have is Jim Jordan the
Ohio Congressman
now I do believe he could and should
Garner the full support of the GOP
conference and can best articulate
that's for sure he's the best guy at
labeling lists of what Democrats do
wrong and what Republicans do right of
anybody in Washington and I think he can
articulate that agenda to the country
Jordan is vowing to finish the job on
the three fundamental things that the
house must do pass the bills like the
Border bill hr2 which they had already
passed that need to be passed do the
oversight his committee is doing it
Judiciary oversight house Ways and Means
Committee and reign in spending control
our borders it sounds simple but with a
tiny tiny minuscule majority well the
fact is they've got many competing
factions inside the GOP that is just the
reality it is easier said than it is
done and between the 18 moderate
Republicans in Districts The Joe Biden
won and conservatives in safe districts
there is often a big divide they have to
come together moving forward House
Republicans need to do that on on
several new protections it's this simple
as a caucus as a conference they're
either going to succeed together or
they're going to fail together it's not
going to be this group of Republicans
win and the other group of Republicans
lose no either they win or the Democrats
win and they need to remember who the
real enemy is whose policies are hurting
you the American people this country who
needs to really be replaced that would
be the Democrats and together well with
the next GOP speaker whoever that might
be they've got to be given the chance to
serve for at least the rest of this
218th Congress in other words the now
Infamous one-person threshold for a
motion to vacate that has to go away
with this majority it becomes impossible
to govern that way especially when you
got 221 people that all have their own
personal views the next speaker they
will have 15 months to prove themselves
and then come January of 2025
Republicans if they're happy with the
job of the new speaker they can either
vote that person speaker to be to be
speaker again if they are not well okay
they can be unified and bring in the
next person or if they're not careful
they might be voting for the next
minority leader if they don't get the
job done the patience of the American
people is on a short leash here now if
the sound of speaker Hakeem Jeffries
doesn't sit well with conservatives and
Republicans uh perhaps that will be
motivation enough to come together and
get the job done and finally it is
imperative that House Republicans pick a
speaker quickly we don't have time for
15 votes the first round of votes are
going to take place next Tuesday uh
probably either Tuesday or Wednesday
actually and this needs to be wrapped up
as quickly as expeditiously as possible
we are now on the cusp of a critical
presidential election and the house has
a very key important role to play they
need to hold together they need to hold
the line against against the radical
left and their insane agenda they need
to continue their oversight into Joe
Biden what I'm calling the Joe Biden
bribery and money laundering Scandal
allegations they've got to keep their
feet to the fire we cannot live in a
country with a dual system of justice
and a weaponized FBI in a weaponized doj
they need to demonstrate the obvious
benefits of the conservatism the
conservative agenda you know one with
less spending less inflation less woke
total BS fewer government restrictions
lower gas prices energy security border
security safety in every city every town
in this country so Americans can pursue
happiness a free and fair Judiciary that
applies the law not judicial activism
and Republicans need to stop fighting
each other right now and focus on what
has become a radical Democratic party
that is turning the this country upside
down and has put 66 percent of this
country living paycheck to paycheck and
many can't make their monthly payments
and by the way all while they're
decrepit frankly president Withers on
the vine right before our very eyes and
of course socialist Roots they're trying
to remake America they want you to owe
nothing and to have no basic rights they
want to pick your appliances they want
to pick your car they want to replace
personal responsibility with
collectivism they want to eliminate
America's borders all together and
Destroy American Pride they are ruthless
in their unending mission to transform
this country away from capitalism now is
the time for republicans and
conservatives you must Now quickly come
together and fight back hard do it on a
United front now in a signal of things
to come the speaker Pro tem Patrick
McHenry well he just evicted both steny
Hoyer and Nancy Pelosi from their
special Hideaway offices in capital
by the way
that was a good move it is time for the
GOP to be unrelenting against Democrats
and radical socialists instead of each
other for a change Biden is the worst
president in American history let's not
give Democrats and the mob and the media
a sideshow to distract them from their
failures their policies are hurting each
and every American in this country it's
time to get America back on track and to
use the phrase bring this country back
to Greatness again we need that
desperately hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else